all right let's talk I want to talk
about the fighter uh this is an
incredible movie it's an absolutely true
story yeah of this uh amazing uh amazing
fighter Mickey Ward and uh you shot the
film on location in Lowell with your
sister exactly okay no that's not that's
the time my sister there's a there's a
number of Mickey Wards has a number of
sisters and my sister Kate is in the
movie playing one of the sisters
blast she does an amazing job
uh so that's why you gotta go see the
movie but no she did an amazing job and
and uh she loved the experience but
she's told me when she was shooting it
uh with you guys that they were shooting
in Lowell and that there's a lot of to
get the real local character you did the
movie with uh just a lot of real people
who were there watching you make it yeah
they're Mickey and Dicky who are the two
brothers
um that the movie centered around they
were there almost every day and then the
real sisters would come by and um the
character that I played Charlene didn't
come by as much which I was grateful for
because that would have been really
intimidating this is I think a great
role for you get to show this whole
other side and the language that you get
to use I mean uh your character salty
language is what my mother would say
there's some salty language in this film
but yeah I I yeah a little bit uh
there's a scene where I'm
uh swearing a lot a lot a lot and uh
Dave I like ran out of swear words
because David's like yeah throw me some
more throw me some more swear words I
was like she's the director the director
yeah because he was doing it over I
don't know over an intercoms he was
going to be cutting in and out and then
I'm yelling out the window and I ran out
of swear words I'm like I can do
different combinations of swear words
like you know
cable I can swear
no
no it's like you're so trained to not
ever swear yeah I mean for you I don't
even know if I could yeah it's all
different here I don't even wear pants
on this show
don't look back there it's a freak Show
uh but um yeah but so so you run out of
swear words and what's he telling you
he's just saying like improvise new
swear words yeah yeah I mean uh I I he
was I was trying um like instead of I
can't swear
instead of like I don't have to do
anything you're uncomfortable doing
Andy throw out some swear words
uh okay
[Applause]
and he's got a giant Rolodex filled with
that he's like all right if only he'd
been on set I could have helped you out
no my personal favorite was
but
sorry as the character because
in the accent it's particularly I love
that you're holding back and then you go
for that one
I think I can Andy you took the almost
the most polite one and then you go
nuclear on us
think of that as a swear I think if that
is a beautiful thing
question of love and affection
this show on air tonight
the transcript will be available you can
please bleep me out no no we're not
going to do that actually this is going
to be in the promo when we're not
bleeping at it
we're showing this in Finland on a giant
screen tomorrow
um this is a very physical role I know
when my sister Kate was telling me she
was she said that she had one scene
where all the sisters are fighting with
you I then saw the movie there's a very
intense scene they're all fighting with
you you look like you're really you guys
are really having a fight it's not a
Hollywood fight where there's a punch
and someone is clearly not heard it
looked like you were really physically
trying to hurt each other uh yeah David
wanted it to look like we were getting
hurt and so that's very hard to do
without getting hurt so
you know there was hair flying we just
went for it you just went for it I
didn't hit anyone in the face I was
afraid I was going to but um right yeah
I was hit in the face growing up my
sister put you in the face my sister hit
me in the face why did your sister hit
you in the face my teeth were taking a
long time falling out my mom said would
your teeth ever fall out
and she said house is this your mother's
in the corner lifting a stove
knock her teeth out
right
so she did that she just she was kidding
but ever since then I've been afraid of
fake punches
Fair